c'est un nouveau souffle pour le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron le revers
subi par la république en marche aux
élections municipales a convaincu le
président de la nécessité de remanier
son gouvernement
ils se séparent donc de son premier
ministre à deux ans de la fin de son
mandat l'occasion d'un nouveau départ
pour edouard philippe qui a multiplié
les déplacements ces dernières semaines
entre l'elysée et la cité normande
le locataire de matignon avait laissé
entrevoir la possibilité d'un éventuel
départ du gouvernement pour reprendre sa
casquette de maire mon objectif c'est
d'être maire du havre vite ça peut
arriver très vite si ça arrive très vite
ça sera très bien
l'épidémie de coronavirus a poussé
emmanuel macron à ouvrir le troisième
acte de son quinquennat la crise
sanitaire a fragilisé la majorité
déstabilisé par les tensions sociales
permanente et avec l'arrivée de la crise
économique le président a dû poser un
acte fort en se séparant de son homme
providentiel pour reprendre la main au
cours de ces trois dernières années
edouard philippe a maintes fois servi de
bouclier à emmanuel macron notamment
face aux mouvements des gilet jaune
le premier ministre avait alors défendu
la réponse ferme de l'exécutif pour face
aux débordements lors des manifestations
à paris
on va utiliser tous les moyens de droit
et toutes les mobilités tout le
dynamisme dont nous pouvons faire preuve
pour répondre à ceux qui viennent mettre
en cause les forces de l'ordre mettre en
cause la propriété privée vous
m'entendez bien nous allons mettre en
voit tous les moyens de droit et tous
les moyens dans la mobilisation dans la
stratégie des forces de l'ordre pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions
apporter une réponse qui ne rendent plus
possible ses actes un recours à la force
présent également dans le processus
législatif le premier ministre avait
engagé la responsabilité du gouvernement
sur la réforme controversée des
retraites
l'article 49 alinéa 3 a permis
l'adoption du projet en première lecture
avant les élections municipales
mais la crise sanitaire a ensuite amené
emmanuel macron
à geler toutes les réformes conformément
à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution de 1958 et après en avoir
obtenu l'autorisation du conseil des
ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi
alors que c'est la fin du règne des
doigts félipe à la tête du pouvoir
gouvernemental
la cote de confiance du maire du havre
poursuit sa progression avec 51%
d'opinions favorables soit un gain de 13
points depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire durant laquelle il a été très
exposé